hey everyone we are back at women and
Technology International we are now
sitting down with Sara do it hi good to
see you thanks for coming out of the
show it's so happy to be here and so you
are a VP at PBS KIDS Digital that's
right and this has been something that I
mean PBS KIDS
I remember watching a decent amount of
when I was young and you're you guys are
still around and you're now you're
exploring personalized learning
augmented reality technology
keek emotional intelligence skills for
kids making the screen time worthwhile
and meaningful so tell us about all this
what I think you know you just said you
know we're still around and then and and
you seem surprised that we're doing all
these interesting things and I think
it's something really fun that people
don't realize is that PBS has been kind
of experimental from the beginning we're
about to have a 50 year anniversary and
if you haven't watched the Senate
testimony that Fred Rogers did your PBS
funding you should take a look because
it's really inspiring to anyone in media
not just someone from PBS about how this
new media this thing that people are
calling the vast wasteland could
actually be a really powerful tool for
for helping kids learn and for effecting
change in the world and for not just
pandering to the worst parts of human
nature that's what he talks about
violence and contempt and condescension
but to really look at the ways that you
could spread kindness through this media
so Fred Rogers was actually quite a
revolutionary I mean you really change
things have you seen the new documentary
I have it yet yeah I'm going this week I
choose I missed it with my team they all
went yesterday back in DC so yeah so
you're going to see you soon I know this
week for sure
so he really he paved the way Jim Henson
paved the way a lot of like luminaries
in public media kind of set the tone for
this is a place where we're going to
look at this tool not as a big marketing
platform but as a way to
promote how to be a good citizen and
education and ways to make your life
more fulfilling and so through that
through the years we've had this
opportunity to keep experimenting with
new technologies to think about okay you
know augmented reality is popping up as
something that like is a marketers dream
but how would I use that in an
educational space like how would this
tool actually help me understand how big
cliff or their big red dog really is you
know or how bet how big
like if you're a Dinosaur Train viewer
how big a Tyrannosaurus Rex really would
be next to my house you know what is the
possibility for education and so we have
been so fortunate to have grants and
different opportunities to really
experiment with it to say like screen
time doesn't have to be this experience
that is just drawing you in and sucking
you in and wasting all of your time
screen time can actually be something
that inspires a passion for learning
that makes you want to put down that
screen and go outside and see what you
can learn about it and that's that's
really what PBS is about like that's
that's where we that's where we are
that's where we sit yeah have you hung
out with uh Nehru Khosla yeah no oh man
we gotta make that happen we'll make
that happen she did this she started the
ck-12 foundation oh wait yes yeah GNA
where we spoke she looked right before
me yesterday and we were sitting at
lunch together now we both were about to
go on stage so we weren't at our most
chatty but yes she was great
yeah you guys would hit it off because
she definitely knows how to leverage
technology for mm-hmm the use of a
better education for kids we'll make
sure that happens and then also Vivian
Ming who's a theoretical neuroscientist
out of Berkeley um we had the pleasure
of working with her almost like four
years ago about maximizing potential for
kids with these daily emotionally and
cognitively challenging activities for
kids that my parents could have with
their kids and machine learning so it's
being tailored to the kids across all
different socio-economic statuses so
we'll have to make some
solid pushes to help with that's great
yeah so it's been like 20 years for you
now so you've always you've seen like
quite a bit happen in the last 20 years
with tech and with basically what you
just described which was technology
coming in and being like marketing and
advertising and now it's like let's see
how we can make this actually enhance
the human evolution from a child's age
and help them grow so I guess like tell
us because this is so interesting it's
been a it's been 19 years the PBS and
like you said I was so surprised that it
was like saying that you guys were
exploring with augmented reality and
personalized learning so I guess what
are some of the things then that you are
exploring right now and how the
evolution got there mm-hmm well um if
you think about the audience I'm focused
on it's kids between the ages of 2 and 8
and so there is a huge design challenge
right out of the gate those kids the
majority of them can't read or write and
so right out of the gate we're thinking
about how how does the technology how
can we make the technology itself more
transparent so that a kid can get into
an experience so you know if you think
about when I started in 1999 I was
working on the first pbskids.org website
and we were in focus groups with three
and four-year-olds who were trying to
figure out how to navigate a keyboard
and a mouse and they didn't know the
difference between left and right so
clicking those things meant they were
constantly changing the wallpaper on the
computer while we were trying to test
games and they didn't have the fine
motor skills to scroll so we had to keep
everything above the folds and we
realized in testing that a four-year-old
could handle three options on screen and
a seven-year-old could handle maybe
seven or eight options on screen and the
colors really mattered so I mean colors
this is really like you know it was just
a really interesting time so if you
think about like how things have evolved
like the major disrupter in
the world but definitely in the kids
gaming industry was the touchscreen
because all of a sudden and you weren't
trying to like use these tools for
grown-ups like these the design for
grown-ups
you weren't trying to force kids to use
these tools they could naturally you
know swipe with no problem and that
meant like just this amazing amazing
Renaissance like kind of period started
where you didn't have to start by
explaining to kids how to use the
technology you could just jump right in
and get them right into the experience I
know that he worked mouse the keyboard
mouse to touchscreen was such a massive
transition for you kids for kids yes for
learning from computer Wow
right yeah now what's funny is we
sometimes I mean we still have a huge
number of desktop users or laptop users
it really kind of surprises me every
month in our stats but we will go into
testing sometimes and we want to test
things on multiple platforms and we will
have a kid on a touchscreen and move
them to a computer and say okay can you
use the mouse and the kid will say
there's a mouse you know like they don't
know what it is you know they've never
heard of it and so it really is a
different time now and kids can get into
it so the next big revolution I think is
going to be voice yeah because you know
the touchscreen still if you wanted a
child to make an input that was that is
more creative they can't really they
still can't type they still don't know
how to write and so if they can talk to
it then we suddenly have an opportunity
for kids to tell a story or answer a
question that we wouldn't have have been
able to ask in the past and so that's
really where we're doing the most
experimentation right now is trying to
think about what is a safe and secure
way to do that that's always like the
very first step but how can this
technology actually unlock a whole new
opportunity for learning and for the
folks creating the content under
and the kids learning you know on both
sides so we go from mouse and keyboard
to touchscreen and now to voice mm-hmm
did you meet with Kathy pearl from the
conversational interfaces at Google
no no she make that I thought you she's
so interesting you got a chance to sit
down with her she's conversational
interfaces and the future of that and
now the way that kids get to engage
these conversational interfaces even to
a point where we're just on our living
room table and we're just conversing
with our official intelligence and we're
just talking about the way that we feel
we're maybe talking about what we were
doing tomorrow and what we're doing last
week it's just very uh it's very
interesting how kids are gonna use voice
for at the age of two to interact with
an artificial intelligence the other
voice that's crazy and it's kind of
already happening a little bit with
Alexa and Amazon and yeah Apple and
Google systems and it is my my kids um
we have we had a Google home in our
house for now maybe six months and they
hear us to ask about the weather they
hear us ask for sports scores and
they've only just in the last week or so
started asking question my kids are six
and three and they just every day or
asking for a joke like that's that's it
it's like the joke-telling machine okay
google tell me a joke yeah and the jokes
are pretty corny and but but perfect for
a six and a three-year-old we'll heard
it said what kind of a bird is always
out of breath a puffin yes yeah oh yeah
so they love the jokes eleven jokes now
with the the line we have to really like
be careful about is the children's
ability to separate fantasy from reality
and so this is something that we are
always kind of thinking about and
watching it's why we aren't doing any
experiments with virtual reality right
now because you know not only do we not
have good information on how that might
affect a child's
optical development or neurological
development but we do know from lots of
research that happen early in the years
of television that young kids can't
differentiate a commercial from content
even if the characters were totally
different even if the tone is different
or the music's different there's a
certain age where kids are finally able
to understand like oh that's a different
thing than this was yes and the few
people I know who have let their kids
play with virtual reality kids under the
age of seven they all have reported the
same kind of slightly disturbing
response which is that their kids had
difficulty separating that from their
own real memories yeah so the example
like one example is a child who was
doing a virtual reality scuba diving
experience and then a few weeks later
thought that he really had gone
snorkeling and just didn't remember the
boat ride and was asking his dad how
they got there you know so these kinds
of things we do have to be really
careful about and we need to think about
like there's a there are places with the
technology where we really have to step
back and think about okay I can see an
interesting potential here but what's
best for the kid it's not best for the
kid to confuse you know reality with
fantasy in this kind of way
and so this is where we need to kind of
step back a little bit so when you're
talking about conversing with AI you
know the that's another thing that I
think we really need to think about a
lot is and there's some interesting like
early research happening right now on
how much kids are anthropomorphizing
these devices like do they think it's
actually a person do they think it's a
thing are they they they feel bad for it
when it's put in the closet but then you
also have parents complaining that kids
aren't being polite to it because it
doesn't ask you for please and thank you
you know so so there's this whole like
variety of things that we still have to
think about when we're dealing with with
content for kids and it's yeah it's
really important to to be doing the
research
I mean if we go back to front Rodgers
for a minute like he met with the child
development experts
I think weekly yeah and they would just
have long conversations about where kids
were and what they were learning and and
then would constantly retool his scripts
to make sure that the language was as
unambiguous as possible to be as clear
as possible and so it's kind of like I
feel like that's a great model for
people to understand it looks so simple
and easy and you're like oh it's for
kids but it actually content for kids
takes a lot of thought and care and
constant assessment of what how is this
going to live within a child's world
yeah because that's it how is this gonna
live within child's world mmm and the
example that you gave was nuts so giving
virtual reality to kids before the age
of seven seems like it confuses them a
lot about what is real versus what's
fantasy and even though the fantasy
might expand their mind to new areas of
thought as though they got the chance to
go in below the ocean surface and
explore a marine life that's both very
awareness expanding for them to have
done that but also can get them confused
at times and think that they might have
actually went and done that so now the
quote now there's a lot of question
around when is the right then time for
for kids to howl or maybe how can we get
kids at an earlier age to understand the
difference between the reality and the
fantasy as though maybe there's a aspect
of integration that happens afterward
after they have the experience where we
integrate them into hey so that was a
virtual reality experience so you
learned about what it would be like to
be there but remember you were sitting
in this chair the whole time so you
didn't actually go there physically but
we mentally took you there see these
words for a seven-year-old to be like
what are you talking about right yeah
they just it's you have to think about
like child development like cognitive
they might not be there yet they might
not be at a point where they can
understand that distinction yeah this
this that and then the the Google home
getting put in the closet is just
interesting time interesting times and
you're breaking down a lot of very
fascinating kind of like philosophy and
ethics and even neurological development
in children like you're breaking down a
lot of really important things for us
what are some of these other like
interesting takeaways that you guys have
been like uncovering well the the
research that we're really deep in right
now is on how you use gameplay data to
better understand what a child is
learning and so that's what I actually
was here to speak about at this
conference was about the data analysis
we're doing for for learning and the
things that we've we've been doing and
this is all in conjunction with our
producers and in partnership with a team
at UCLA but things we've been doing are
taking games that have been created to
teach certain subjects like math and
science and UCLA is working with us to
do really specific feature analysis of
those games so what is every single
moment in the game that could be telling
you something about a child's
understanding of that concept so you
know people who develop games know this
like you can see like you know they've
they've paused for a long time before
they clicked on something or they made
three wrong attempts before they got a
right attempt and you we often kind of
calibrate a game to like help people
through that path or give them the right
hints at the right time but layering
kind of like the academic learning goals
on top of that kind of opens up a whole
other idea like what what does it tell
you about the way a child navigated this
math game about how well they understand
the concept of measurement or how
weights were found a pan balance so we
did we've done a bunch of experiments on
this right now but the most kind of
widely publicized was one on Curious
George and that show is based on an
engineering curriculum from NBC
Universal and
WGBH in Boston who is a PBS member
station produces a lot of the content
within the show so they produced the
games and they made a series of
preschool math games they were focused
on kids you know between the ages I
think it was three and five and it was
really basic like numeracy counting and
the games really kind of walkthrough
kids walked kids through these skills so
when we have the opportunity we do pre
and post-testing with kids playing these
games and so in this case they brought a
group of kids in they gave them a test
about math and they have them play the
games and did another test and they
could see that there was a statistically
significant gain and their understanding
of the math concepts so that's a win
that's great
but then we wonder it okay if we put
this on the Curious George website PBS
KIDS digital products have over 12
million unique visitors a month if we
put this on the carry storage website
we're going to get so much data like
there's just gonna be so much collected
as kids are playing so UCLA worked with
us to do this feature analysis what
could we understand about how well kids
understood counting and basic numbers
based on these games and so then they
did another trial and they used gameplay
data to create a neural net and they
took a group of kids they recruited I
think it was 85 kids all from title one
schools so that's kids who go to schools
who are likely to have free or reduced
lunch and brought them in and had them
take a math assessment so it was like a
standardized test and then they used the
correlation of their gameplay data with
that math assessment to create a neural
net to train the computer to try to
guess to predict the child's test score
based on their gameplay data but they
had kept a few kids out of the data pool
and they started running their data
through to see okay what would the
computer predict and the accuracy was
unbelievable the computer was like
predicting with a really high level of
accuracy what the kids test scores would
be just
based on what they did in these Curious
George games so it was a huge takeaway
for us and there was a white paper
published in the Journal of children in
media and I know UCLA has been talking
about this a lot just that these games
weren't actually built to assess a kid's
math abilities but that turned out to be
a byproduct and what that means is if we
can assess a kid's like you know if we
can assess their skill development or
their mastery of a certain subject then
we actually have this opportunity to
send a text message to the parent or to
the teacher and say here's here's
something that you could be working on
or here's where they're knocking it out
of the park like it kind of can help
with individualized learning yeah and
maybe test anxiety you know like what if
you can play these games and know more
than you would if kids had to sit down
and take this scary test so that work
has been really interesting and we're
taking that now into adaptive games so
if we can assess what a child knows how
then can we modulate the game to kind of
stay in that kids zone of proximal
development in the gaming world you
would just say flow you know that that
perfect place where it's just hard
enough and interesting enough that you
want to keep playing but not too hard
that you bail yeah so it's like really
fascinating yeah that is so interesting
we've had good amounts of ever since we
were talking about Vivian mingle about
four years ago and then all the way up
to you know Nehru COSO who's just with
us yesterday that there's been a lot and
also with Adams Ezeli and Eddie Mair to
Chi from Achille interactive labs that
are going through the process of helping
kids with ADHD with video games
prescribing video games going through
trials to be able to do that so now
we're entering an era of being able to
play games that are tailored in our zone
of proximal development
and that being potentially more
efficacious than a test is and less
anxiety than a test and that is mind
blowing and that's a huge field that is
is growing and I'm happy that you're
also at the forefront of that so is that
then is that mostly used with Curious
George right now the the site and the
different games that they're playing and
being able to have the computer analyze
how where their movements are and is
that mostly on Curious George or where
else yeah where is that it's kind of
across the board so I should say this is
this research was funded by a grant from
the US Department of Education called
ready to learn and so we've been
incredibly fortunate that we can do this
kind of research we started with math
and so we did this on this group of
Curious George games we also launched an
app that's free called measure up and
that is Curious George games no sorry
it's not Kari storage it is instead the
Science Kid from the jim henson company
peg plus cat which is a really fabulous
math show that's just a lot of fun and
that's from the Fred Rogers productions
team and then also Dinosaur Train which
is also from the Jim Henson Company and
so this app then uses this learning
analytics platform across all of it and
then if parents log in and sync an
account to it then they then can see a
dashboard of what their kids doing
within this app wait what's this app
called it's called measure up that's how
most kids measure up it's in more
different games oh no it's like 25
different games but from three different
properties these property okay oh that's
this so great your collaborators are
making this oh yeah got together again
oh this sounds really fun well that this
link in the bio to measure up yeah to
that so measure up is there and then we
also have launched two new games with
different properties now doing this same
learning analytics platform with science
so one of them is the ruff Ruffman show
it is a short form animated series that
it's really fun with a dog he used to be
the star of fetch with ruff Ruffman so
people who were watching PBS KIDS eight
or nine years ago would have seen that
show but he's back and doing science
experiments and so those games are
available on the PBS KIDS games app
which is also free the the game that has
the
most adaptive working it is called fish
force it's really fun and then a new app
from the cat mahat and it was a lot
about that from Random House in
portfolio but dr. Seuss content called
the cat mahat builds that builds that oh
that's cool and so also free in the app
stores I can will link to all of it but
that one is working again with the
scientific inquiry process so
specifically trying to get kids to ask
questions make predictions test their
hypotheses and then go back and you know
see if they can tweak their design and I
love that really really fun for you yeah
my favorite game on that app is the
slight of Mizzou and so you're building
slides and the app is asking you to it's
basically telling you who you want to
win these two slides kind of in a slide
race and so you have the option to make
a slide higher or make it lower but then
as you keep progressing you can spread
sand on a slide or you can put butter on
a slide you know and like what happens
now that there's some friction what
happens now that there's some grease so
it's really fun good opportunity for
kids experiment that exact game that you
just described would be a perfect
simulation
Neru Coast lows yeah yeah as well so
there's got to be a lot of I'm sure a
lot of crossover yeah yeah there okay
let's ask just a couple other questions
you're also working especially in lower
income households aiming to target into
that can tell us a little bit about that
is where at the women technology
international so also young women as
well right yep so that is part of Public
Media's mission is to be accessible to
as wide an audience as possible and we
focus very specifically on kids from
lower-income communities when we're
designing content and testing content
and someone just the other day asked me
then well then how do you how do you
know what background somebody is coming
from so you know what content to serve
up and I was like no it's not like that
if you're
if you're designing and testing content
with lower-income kids it's not like
they have completely different needs
than higher income kids in this kind of
realm it just means we're we're thinking
about how to make our content more
broadly accessible or thinking about the
vocabulary we're using we're thinking
about the ways that we kind of like
scaffold a design thinking they might
not have used this technology as much as
a kid who has has more resources but the
content itself isn't different it still
works for every kid a childhood
development really for everyone mm-hmm
yeah but just we're really testing and
intentional in those neighborhood app
t'v - yeah and I think the way that it
plays out the most for us is the
platforms we deliver our content on so a
lot of for-profit companies can focus on
like the latest versions of the phones
coming out the latest iOS the latest
operating systems and higher end
technologies and are thinking about all
like streaming platforms we are on all
the streaming platforms and we are on
all of those plot all the newer
platforms but we also go way back
we look at you know tablets that came
out four and five years ago we're
looking at desktops like where we're
testing our content on browsers that a
lot of folks wouldn't test on anymore
because we know those are the browsers
that are being used in yes you know
community centers and libraries that are
in schools and that means that our
content is accessible to those populace
in 2017 PBS KIDS made of what sounded
like a really bizarre decision we
launched a 24 hour multicast broadcast
channel and you know the industry was
sort of like what you know broadcast is
dead what are we doing our ratings have
gone up 14% and it is really because
kids and lower-income areas kids who
don't have cable and who don't have
persistent broadband access we're
watching a lot of television and after 6
7 o'clock at night
eight the TV was still on but there was
nothing appropriate for them yeah and
now there's 24-hour PBS KIDS and you
wouldn't believe all the letters that
have come in my grandma's who are
watching their kids well the well their
grandchildren well parents are on her
second shift
yeah from hospitals saying this is
fantastic we now have something to turn
on for kids at two o'clock in the
morning when they have to have like you
know their meds well just from all kinds
of families just so grateful that now
there's something they can put their
kids in front of and it seems it seems
backwards it seems counterintuitive but
the truth is there is still a huge
population out there that isn't on the
latest technology and so totally that's
how we have to think yep it's kind of
like where do we need to be that maybe
isn't the most lucrative place yeah
well it's interesting because you're
both at the forefront evolved this
adaptive tech and learning tech and
computing and they're also going back to
making sure that you're still able to
help people that are using slightly
older technologies and make sure that
they're still having optimal child
development as well that is very cool
PBS rocks thank you I think so and it's
um it's a funny it's also a different
way of describing or defining the word
innovation because we tend to think of
innovation as so bleeding-edge and it is
yeah but it also I got to tell you like
the developers on the PBS KIDS team the
producers we work with they are so
creative about how to design and program
something to work on a lower end tablet
like that also takes some pretty amazing
creative thinking and and design talent
and and it's it's a different way of
stretching your brain so you know
cutting edge of innovation out here and
then the cutting edge of innovation like
just like a little bit behind it but
maybe out a bit towards the side and it
and then up as well it's so it's it's
hard to to put it into a design but it's
so important like you said for for your
team to be creative in that sense as
well uplifting everyone a couple lasts
rapid-fire questions
Tom Sara what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world oh
my goodness
well I immediately got a picture of a
place when you said that and it is in
East Tennessee where my grandmother
lived and where I used to spend every
summer and where kids could just like
climb and roll down hills so yes yes the
climbing and rolling down hills yes yeah
okay yeah and everything that we get to
gain from those types of experiences um
hearing a preschooler laugh that is one
of the most beautiful things ever like a
really good solid belly laugh like they
just thought that was the most hilarious
thing how about do you think we're alone
in the cosmos
ah no but I don't have anything to back
that up I just can't imagine that we are
and do you think that we're in a
simulation oh my gosh isn't that funny
well I remember um seeing the matrix for
the first time in being like this is
what I've always wondered about um no I
don't think we are um but it doesn't
mean we shouldn't always be watching out
to make sure we aren't thank you so much
have you thanks for teaching us about
everything that you're up to both at
this super cutting edge of technology
but also the cutting edge of bringing
other people into the equation this is
such great work and thanks for enriching
us in the audience about it everyone
thank you for tuning in if you guys had
a good time make sure to share the
content with other people go check out
the links in the bio share those measure
up with other people around you other
kids especially comment below with your
thoughts subscribe and join us in this
movement
join us on patreon as well we need to
continue coming to great places like
Women in Technology International and
highlighting really smart people from
around the world so join us there thank
you very much thanks Sarah thank you
we'll talk to you soon
good
you